[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: We want to
make AI technology
for image analysis easily
accessible for enterprises.
So we created Cloud
AutoML Vision.
Currently, to perform image
analysis on Google Cloud
Platform, developers
can use the Vision API
to access a pre-trained
model or design and train
a custom model with Cloud
Machine Learning Engine.
Let's say you're a
meteorologist and want
to train a model to identify
different types of clouds--
like cumulus,
cumulonimbus, or stratus--
to predict upcoming weather
patterns or flight plans.
If you tried this
with the Vision API,
here are the labels
you'd get back.
It wasn't trained
specifically to identify
different types of clouds.
What if you want
to train a model
to classify images
specific to your dataset,
without writing model code?
Cloud AutoML Vision lets
businesses and developers
with limited machine learning
expertise train custom vision
models for their own use cases.
Developers can upload their own
labeled or unlabeled data set,
train and manage their models,
and use those models directly
from the Cloud to
make predictions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Let's take a look
at the AutoML UI.
Begin by uploading your
images to Cloud AutoML.
Then, press the Train button
to train a custom model
on your image data set.
When training completes,
analysis and stats
of the model quality
are available directly
in the AutoML UI.
Next, use your model to generate
a prediction on new data,
either in the UI or with
a simple REST API call.
This process is easy
from start to finish.
Simply upload your data
and Cloud AutoML Vision
will handle scalably
training and serving
the high quality model.
You can learn more here.